uh so you started talking about smart
contracts but uh
let's zoom back out and ask
uh the big question here is what is a
blockchain
and what is a cryptocurrency so
blockchain is just a ledger
and really it has three nice properties
you're time stamped you're immutable and
auditable
either in a global or a local sense and
so there's all kinds of things
mankind has invented where it's really
important that
you when you put some information down
it doesn't change
and other people can see it uh and that
you know when it was put down for
example a property ledger
so when you buy land or you have rights
associated with land like mineral rights
or water rights or these things
you'd like to transitively see how does
it go from alice to bob to charlie to
jim and so forth and
what was the state of these things as
they were transitioning so how much did
they pay
you know when did it occur et cetera et
cetera the metadata that follows that
okay well normally these types of
ledgers are so important that they're
managed either by governments or
regulated entities
and the issues are that while they can
be efficient they're generally brittle
the political manipulation and they're
brittle to
geopolitical events for example when
syria fell apart
you know the very first thing isis did
they started saying hey
the ownership of the land it's going to
fundamentally change we've decided that
you know this guy over here now owns all
these things
and then when peace comes like how do
you unwind all of that put it all back
together
uh so the the power of a blockchain is
that it gives you a transnational way
of sorting all these details out putting
all together in
in in in a place that you know that even
if it's inconvenient to a very
powerful actor that it will still stay
preserved
this is an asymmetry we haven't had as a
society usually kings and empires
they have the ability to decide what's
true and then suddenly you have this
asymmetrical thing that is above them
kind of like a synthetic laws of physics
and once something goes in there
you know that that's there okay so
that's the first part of it the second
part of it is that
it's auditable meaning that instead of
saying
only the high cleric or the president
or you know some very special club of
people get to see what's going on
suddenly now all the people can actually
see who owns what where
like imagine a tax system where you know
the pro public club just leaked
the the taxes of all these different
billionaires and said well how much do
they make and how much they pay
well imagine a tax system where that's
just done by default
or any other social systems where this
type of information is put in by default
so it's tremendously useful this type of
structure and all kinds of things
medical records supply chains
you know just a good thought experiment
as i travel a lot i've been to 52
countries in the last five years
imagine if i got sick in zimbabwe you
know i get hit by a car or something and
i'm unconscious
and a zimbabwean doctor calls my doctor
in colorado and says hey you know i need
all charles's medical records
you know he's unconscious right now but
i needed to treat him because he's quite
ill
they'd say who is this person in
zimbabwe why i don't know you i can't
give you his records i need his consent
oh no he's unconscious in the hospital
can't do it
well a broker system that would allow
the movement of medical records would be
an example of what a blockchain could
potentially do in the foreseeable future
cryptocurrency is just an application
that runs on top of blockchain because
it turns out that when you issue
property you also can issue tokens of
value
and then you could have a monetary
policy it could be inflationary or
deflationary you know demirage where it
decays over time or
whatever have you uh and the very same
mechanics that
would ensure your property records are
secure your medical record access is
secure could also be applied for the
ownership of the cryptocurrency and
again you can either be
completely transparent and everybody can
see what everybody owns and that's what
bitcoin does
or you can be as opaque as you seek to
be that's what zcash
basically attempts to do it says hey
let's keep these things as private as
possible
but they have relatively the same
mechanics in terms of those properties
of auditability and time stamping and
immutability
you know things won't be reversed you
know that people aren't going to
manipulate the timestamps and
you can audit at least enough to know
that the ownership is right
you